إذن ها نحن ذا ، هذا يأتي من ليزا في
شيكاغو ، هل تحتاج إلى ارتداء قناع
إذا تم تطعيمك وأنت بالقرب من
بعض الأشخاص الآخرين الذين تم تطعيمهم
جيدًا ، هذا أه أحد الأسئلة الأكثر شيوعًا
وما زالت التوجيهات الرسمية
نعم  لكن يمكنني أن أخبرك أنني كنت أتحدث
إلى الكثير من الناس حول
هذا وأعتقد أننا
سنسمع أه تغيير في التوصيات بشأن
أنها منخفضة المخاطر ، وأعتقد أن هذه هي الطريقة
للتفكير في الأمر أه أنت  يمكن أن تشعر
بالثقة في أنك لن
تمرض إذا تم تطعيمك ، فربما
لا يزال من المحتمل
أن تحمل
الفيروس ويحتمل أن تنقله
آه نعم يبدو ذلك احتمالًا ضعيفًا ولكن نعم ،
دعنا نقول أنك قد اجتمعت معًا
إذا تلقيت لقاحًا رائعًا ، فأنت تشعر بالثقة في أنك لن
تمرض ، ولكن بمجرد مغادرة هذا
التجمع ،
فأنت بالتأكيد بحاجة إلى ارتداء قناعك
لأنك الآن قد تحمل
الفيروس ولا تريد أن تنشره إلى
شخص لم يتم تطعيمه.  اعتقد ثا  إنها
أبسط طريقة للتفكير في الأمر ، إنها
حقًا تتعلق بالتزامك تجاه
الآخرين
أكثر من حماية نفسك في
تلك المرحلة ، فهذا مفيد حقًا ولكن مع
حصولنا على المزيد من البيانات التي قد تتغير ،
أعني أن التوجيه قد يتغير وكما
تقول
أنت '  لقد أخبرونا طوال الأسبوع أنه
قد تكون هناك بيانات جديدة حول هذا قريبًا
إرشادات جديدة ستأتي قريبًا أم حسنًا سانجاي
أه هنا هذا من لوري في أريزونا
لقاح جونسون جرعة واحدة
وأقل فعالية قليلاً من
موديرنا وفايزر فلماذا لا تعطي ثانية  جرعة
من لقاح جونسون ،
نعم لوري ، لذلك يتم تجربته
الآن ، أعني أنهم بدأوا
تجربة جرعة ثانية في نوفمبر ، لذا يجب
أن نحصل على بعض هذه البيانات قريبًا ، إليك
ما هو مثير للاهتمام وقد تحدثت أنا
وبعض الأشخاص من
جونسون وجونسون حول هذا
ما وجدوه أنه بعد حصولك على
جرعة واحدة
تزيد مناعتك بشكل مطرد ،
نظروا إليها لمدة تصل إلى 28 يومًا ،
لكنهم وجدوا
أن المناعة ج.  تستمر في التحسن لمدة تصل إلى
57 يومًا ،
لذا فإن السؤال المطروح في هذه المرحلة هو
أساسًا بعد شهرين
إذا حصلت على لقطة ثانية
ستكون أحد الأسئلة التي
يحاولون الإجابة عنها
ولكن التوازن هو مقدار
المناعة التي تتمتع بها  الحصول عليها
بسبب تلك اللقطة الثانية نظرًا
لوجود جميع أنواع التحديات اللوجستية ،
فمن الواضح أنه من الأسهل إعطاء
نظام طلقة واحدة ، لذا يجب
أن تكون فائدة كبيرة تحصل عليها
من تلك اللقطة الثانية ،
فهم لا يعرفون الإجابة على ذلك
ومع ذلك ، فإن اللقطة الواحدة تؤدي عملاً جيدًا
مرة أخرى ، ولم يمت أحد ممن تلقى
اللقاح ،
ولم يتم إدخال أي شخص إلى المستشفى في شهر واحد ،
لذا أعتقد أن الأشياء
الأكثر أهمية يتم تحقيقها مع تلك
اللقطة الواحدة من جونسون جونسون ، كل هذا
يأتي من كوري الذي  هو من
الأرض ، أعتقد أنه مسجل حاليًا
في اختبار عدم ظهور الأعراض على أساس أسبوعي
مع صاحب العمل
بمجرد أن أحصل على اللقاح الثاني للقاح ، سيتم
قطعه إذا استمر في الاختبار ،
نعم ، الإجابة هي نعم  أعني أن هذه
هي البيانات الدقيقة
ربما أكثر من أي شيء آخر
نحتاج إلى معرفته أه خلال الشهرين المقبلين
مرة أخرى نعلم أن اللقاحات تقوم بعمل رائع
كل هذه اللقاحات
في منع دخول المستشفى
والوفيات ومنعك من الإصابة
بمرض خطير
ولكن ذلك  هل هذا الشيء الآخر الذي
لا تظهر عليك أعراض ، لا توجد لديك أعراض ،
ولكن هل يمنعك اللقاح أيضًا
من الإصابة بالعدوى ،
فلن تعرف ذلك لأنه لا توجد لديك أعراض ، ولكنك لا تعرف ذلك لأنك لا
تعاني من أي أعراض ، ولكنك إذا استمرت في
الخضوع للاختبار ،
يستمر الأشخاص الآخرون في الاختبار
بعد هذه
اللقاحات.  كيف سنكتشف نوعًا
ما على وجه اليقين ما إذا كان اللقاح يمنع العدوى أم لا ،
انظر عندما يتم تطعيم عدد كافٍ من الأشخاص في
البلد ،
فيمكنك أن تقول أساسًا إنني
واثق جدًا من أنني حتى لو كنت أحمل
الفيروس و  قم بنشره على
شخص لن يمرض ،
وسيكون هذا إجراءً مهمًا أيضًا
ولكن في الوقت الحالي من المهم حقًا
معرفة أن اللقاح
بالإضافة إلى  لمنع الأعراض
يمنعك من احتمالية أن تكون
حاملاً لهذا الفيروس أيضًا